hey guys welcome to yet another video by
simply learn
today we shall be learning about the top
10 artificial intelligence technologies
before getting into the video here's a
gentle reminder to subscribe to our
channel and hit that bell icon
so that you can never miss an update
from simply learn
so without further ado let's quickly
jump into the topic
please note that the list is not in any
particular order
so the first one is natural language
generation
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication
humans find it tricky to say the right
words in the right sequence and convey
the message clearly
and when it comes to machines it's much
trickier
natural language generation is a
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence
and is a trendy technology that converts
the structured data into native language
the machines are programmed in such a
way that the algorithms convert the data
into a desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service
report generation and summarizing
business intelligence insights
sample vendors are attabow automated
insights
sas cambridge semantics digital
reasoning
narrative science etc the second one in
the docket is
smart devices with every passing day
smart devices are becoming more popular
and more trendy technologies that people
were using once upon a time
are now remodeled and modified as smart
devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects made
intelligent
with advanced computations which include
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
there are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect share and interact with
its users
and other smart devices some of these
smart devices are
smart watches smart glasses smartphones
smart speakers
etc the third one in the docket is
virtual agents they are computer
generated intelligence
that provides online customer assistance
they can effectively communicate with
humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots
as customer service agents who interact
with us answering our queries
in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology
which aims to create an effective but
digital impersonalization
of humans virtual agents can make
reservations book an appointment
place an order and even avail product
information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents are google assistant
amazon alexa etc etc companies that
provide
virtual agents are microsoft google
amazon and assist ai
next one is speech recognition speech
recognition
is yet another sub-discipline of
artificial intelligence
which is used to convert human speech
into a comprehensive
and useful format for computer
applications to process
it can be set as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans
it is presently used in interactive
voice response systems and mobile
applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are
nuanced communications open text nice
and
warrant systems followed by speech
recognition we have augmented reality
yet another trendy technology in the
field of artificial intelligence
augmented reality is an enhanced version
of real physical world
that is achieved using sound digital
visual elements and other
sensory stimulated delivery via
technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make it a new artificial environment
it
alters the perception of the real world
environment augmented reality is making
its way into several
retail stores that make up selection and
furnishing much
more fun and interactive if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so next we have machine learning machine
learning is an application
and an important branch of artificial
intelligence which refers to machine
being able to learn by themselves
without
being explicitly programmed it enhances
systems to learn and improve from
experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms apis big data
and applications and training tools
enterprises are heavily investing into
machine learning
to rape its benefits for various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization and prediction
sample vendors are amazon fractal
analytics google
microsoft etc followed by machine
learning we have
robotic process automation rpa
configuring a robot to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses scripts and other methods to
automate the human actions
which in turn supports efficient
business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas
where the physical presence of a human
is dangerous feels like a warfare
mining etc where it's currently being
used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans
but instead it is used to complement
their abilities and reinforce human
talent
companies focusing on robotic process
automation are
pega systems automation anywhere blue
prism etc
so followed by rpa we have decision
management
decision management is yet another
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make
violent decisions by providing
up-to-date and relevant information
and performing analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data
to predictive models of key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks
and the automation of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector financial sector
insurance sector e-commerce and many
more
some of the companies that provide this
service are informatica
advanced systems concepts bigger systems
mana
etc next we have deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the working of
human brain and processing data this
data is used for a variety of purposes
like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several industries
for various applications
sample vendors are deep instinct fluid
ai
math works saffron technology etc
and now we have the image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or
feature in a digital image or video
it can be used to analyze clients and
their opinions verify users based on
their faces
detect license plates and diagnose
diseases
the present day image recognition is
comparable to human visual perception
many social media platforms like
facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and
eight visually impaired users clarify
google and sensetime provide this
technology
so with that we have come to an end of
this particular tutorial on top ai
technologies
if you have any queries regarding the
technologies we discussed in this
session or if you feel that we have
missed anything important
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below we'll be happy
to hear it from you
and until next time thank you stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here